Jack how his independent film evolved
since you started and where do you see
it heading well it's a good question I
always felt like when I started to make
my films independent movies which were
probably the early 90s was sort of like
the in a way it sort of the tail end of
a of the first wave of independent
cinema in other words like when I was in
film school in the 80s that's when you
started to see you know Jim Jarmusch
really starting to make you know waves
and Spike Lee and and how heart be and
all these kind of it was like sort of
like the first wave of independent and
then like in the middle 90s this sort of
became much more commercialized as
people studios realized it's like
co-opting it's like anything it's like
when they realize that oh you can make a
movie four hundred million dollars and
it can make a ton of money well let's
like do that you know so he sort of
corporatized and it became a different a
different world and I became a star
driven world you know we're now suddenly
somebody calls you know little miss
sunshine and independent movie and it's
like well you know if it's you know if
it's over a million dollars in Greg
Kinnear now in our commander in your
movie it's not early you know I mean you
can call it an independent movie I mean
look who's that Sundance which was
supposed to be you know what it was
supposed to be it's like none of those
movies are like don't have not have
stars or or even already have
distributor this so that's a different
that's a I think that it changed I think
what's interesting is now that more
people are able to make movies and
because you can self distribute on
YouTube and so forth that that's really
hopeful because it used to be like you
made your movie and if you didn't get a
distributor then you know what I saw now
as many people as you can get it to can
see it in a very clean pristine form so
I mean a lot of people have talked about
that'sthat's that's nothing new I don't
know what's going to happen I don't know
if people are going to I don't think
people are going to make that same jump
anymore like everybody thought well make
a little movie and then I'll become a
big I don't become Steven Spielberg I
don't know if that necessarily happens
anymore I think there's just too many
filmmakers and there's too many
technically
filmmakers so where it's going i don't
know i think there'll be more
independent movies there's certainly
more de pute independent movies made
which is great the trick is always going
to be distribution it's like musics like
weird there's a million great bands out
there how do I know where to find them
unless somebody goes back to your
question about like how do you get
people to click on your thing I think
you just hope that somebody sees it and
that one person passes it and that next
person passes it may be the next person
who passes it too has a blog with a lot
of people following two then it just
sort of disseminates but I don't know I
I would love to see I think because more
is getting made the chances are that
there's more good stuff out there system
now it's going to be a question of
somebody hopefully pointing me in the
direction and saying hey you should
check this out
you